[Music]
Gregg Alba telling you
tiny scooch in focus is weird keep our
bodies aligned here we're gonna watch
the trailer for just cause or just just
cuz you're supposed to say just cause
for official reveal trailer
Tony's played the games I have not just
to give you a recap of what you're
supposed to do in these games Gregg blow
up and go up every they have a bunch of
stuff you just blow it up blow it up
there's like like my real life and also
you got a wingsuit so that's cool sweets
I mean I've been getting back into
gaming this year beat a few games this
year so I'm taking time this year to
catch up and using III trailers as a way
to know what games I should hop onto
next so I can hopefully be fully caught
up by next year a lot to catch up on a
lot to catch up on but hey let's do it
let's go wanna see explosions explosions
this footage might not look good there
was no clear no fear again
there's the rules that changed whoa what
tornado in it and no one was ready for
it
okay hey black hands they are the
world's most powerful private army but
even they should fear what they are
needed Wow these survival yes
[Music]
explosions
[Music]
okay I remember I saw the Just Cause 3
trailer and I barely remember it but now
that I'm like more into gaming again
looking at this trailer just like I got
up on this game this looks like a
freaking awesome Michael Bay movie if I
like Michael Bay movie looks like an
awesome Michael Bay because for because
like I was just saying explosions
constantly ridiculous I love it there's
so many different ways of just killing
people and exploding things that that's
like basically what the game is all
about I'm really hoping that they like
put a lot of structures in this building
the way that they showed like stirring
little towns and stuff cuz in the other
games it mostly had like a lot of areas
just so you could explode and stuff but
this one they have like a few different
little spots I'm like hoping Arland
figure I was like that one
dome the glass dome and he crashed into
if they have more structures like I'm
really excited for something like that
it doesn't really look like they added
too much different stuff they just you
know excitement but I mean other than
like that tornado like they've never had
any like there's whole trailer circles
around the tornado I'll kill these
people and then fly off into the tree
everything seems circling around
whatever the Tauri I don't know if this
tornado is a natural thing or some like
evil genius created some tornado event I
don't know how this game works that's
like a really exciting element to it
just like everything crashing into looks
like he's driving towards the turn a
little bit like we're watching a fast
and furious movie yeah this problem I
ever had with this game was when I was
playing it like the controls are more
arcade arcade style not the best like if
they had if you had like controlling
like I would say GTA did that would make
you want to like use vehicles and stuff
more but mostly all the time you have
like a grappling hook man you have a
wingsuit but most of the time you're
like I just want to blow up something
the wingsuit my way this looks like
action movie fantasy to me I mean he's
on speed boats he's in cars he's
parachuting his wingsuit sees all kinds
of guns
this looks like my 12 year old boys
fantasy and every for fairly I think I'm
20
20:24 year
that's a 21 year in the beginning of it
they said development footage subject to
change in it and there were parts where
it did look like this is gonna be
updated there were certain there are
certain aspects in the trailer like hey
this feels like it was should be updated
but when it is probably gonna be hella
work on a family man I mean this game
works like a blast I mean just cause
it's good just just cuz you guys can I
subscribe to the reject notification
belt they trampled like TV show
reactions and Tony is on the decision
box find him in the Internet's going to
reject Nations John coming at just some
more III coverage with me
Erik Estrada straight off a shift at the
Highway Patrol that's right how often do
you get that near everyday
do you hate that no it's actually worked
out pretty well to my advantage okay
okay yeah you get like some of his
casting calls yeah every now and then
you look great you look great Wow are
you doing well aside from that you're
obviously a pretty big gamer right yeah
okay good cuz you are the all the credit
this video right yeah big weight on your
shoulders good we're gonna check out the
trailer for destiny to a game I know
everything about massive multiplayer
online role-playing all right
well that's all I need to know let's hop
in this is the e3 story revealed trailer
as well a lot of stories today not not
just shots of landscapes
[Music]
ah
[Music]
it's like Megatron got in a fight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but can't leave
[Music]
well now I know everything that happens
in that game they kill that one guy and
it's dope he gets carried away yeah I
mean okay here's what else that of all
the trailers I've seen from this year's
e3 the one that arguably left one the
biggest impacts on me was doomed and
this trailer reminds me of doom if for
one reason
amid the landscape of all these
different trailers with all these
different moody songs yeah big sprawling
landscape I like that they took the very
steady slow pant cuz like the doom
trailers just like yeah this is on a
tonal level I appreciated that about
this I mean slower yeah this doesn't
really give you a whole lot but I mean
it looks amazing I mean like that yeah I
think that's one thing I can appreciate
it with destiny series you know it has
such great Flair and such great
character design and the imagination is
just awesome yeah and I feel like at
least in this nook of gaming it kind of
comes down to like who's Lord whose
aesthetics appreciate the pose because
there are a lot of games I feel like
they're kind of like this sure but I
mean at least in this trailer they've
managed to grip me with it it seems like
you're in for a journey with this yeah
yeah well I appreciated a trailer that
does bother they call this a story
trailer which is kind of ironic no story
but it does feel cinematic yeah and you
know with the games advancing it leaves
you want her and that's good yeah good
cuz you don't necessarily even know what
you're getting into what yeah but you're
you're curious and you're interested
yeah and from what I understand about
these games I mean they're pretty huge
worlds it's like all online right and I
guess they're borrowing the gameplay
mechanics from destiny for Fallout 76
now cuz that's gonna be an all online
co-op experience kind of game but yeah
cool trailer it seems fine looking
forward to seeing what more comes out of
it yeah maybe some actual gameplay we'll
see I mean it could be good alright well
hey comment below leave us your thoughts
if yeah if you caught something
especially special from that 40 seconds
of everything we just got let us know in
the box
below and as always people you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hey reject nation Greg
Alba here I'm dan cyber dance Seibert is
back in action at the reject nation
human beings so did I know my name
it's Alyssa's fiance dan has come back
from e3 but he missed out on seeing this
stuff so I like perfect this is the one
to watch with me that StarLink battle
for Atlas atlas Atlas atlas Atlantis
starfox trailer and we're gonna watch
the gameplay trailer - is this a starfox
game I have very strong opinions about
this from the information you know about
it the starfox thing is new they
revealed this game last year it's
basically you know how amiibo's and like
the Spyro the Dragon toy things that you
can put into the game oh yeah
the basic concept is you have like a
ship toy and you could add weapons to it
and then put it into your game a cool
concept but in order to really enjoy the
game you kind of have to like drop like
hundreds of dollars well let's see if
the game look
[Music]
[Music]
could use a little help here we had guys
yeah yeah wait
[Music]
those were the SNES original things
[Music]
honestly I'm happy to see you I hate
yeah I hate it because oh they do look
it does look cool how it dies
over there babies who like it's a
starfox game right it is a well P
they're making a little but check out
the battlegrounds gameplay trailer now
really quick before we hop on it yeah
yeah it's like I get it I waited so long
for this
only waiting for let's get out there
go show them what's Darla can do yeah
Starling
[Music]
I'd like to be something but like what
are these literature's even there aren't
enough of us we need to find help from
every planet in atlas
nito I mean it just it feels like
the moving of scare in some ways
stronger each of us is exactly you must
feed
Black's isn't going to stop until we end
this
I want to see Starbucks again yeah see
there's the toy
people like doing it concepts cool but
like I'm not the biggest Nintendo fan
and that felt like a Nintendo game to me
I'll MIT starfox 1 was a lot more
exciting to me but then looking at this
trailer I'm like it doesn't really look
like starfox is really in here I think
we watched him out of order
did we I think so huh doesn't matter me
I was at the same opinion even if it was
in Reverse
I know the whole yeah why are you so
upset
this looks honestly I'm not that appeal
to the game it looks like a cheesy
Nintendo game well it looks like a
cheesy game in general the voice acting
looks doesn't look good there we need to
find help from every planet in Atlas
generic baddies space and then on top of
that it's only meant to push out selling
toys ah feels that way right feels that
way right feels that way right feels
that way if you want to have the best
guns and crap on your thing you have to
go to you Oh
Toys R Us rip I guess you go to your
amazon and you order yeah you order like
your ship and then you order your parts
to it and then next thing you know
you're like $200 down because you wanted
to have a missile launcher to your ship
what's the big draw of this game right
now starfox
but what is the starfox just some random
character in here yeah so this isn't a
starfox game no but they're kind of
trying to deceive people into thinking
it's sort of a starfox game I imagine
because he wasn't in any of that first
trip no I think the starfox was supposed
to be like guess who we put its its
Ubisoft so like just how they did Mario
Rabbids this one was like look what we
did we put starfox and another one of
our games aren't we wacky
yeah but why don't we just get a new
star Phi I want a new starfox game
because I was I was happy when I saw its
the heart was excited I was happy of a
genuinely thrilled when I start like
this goes one of two ways okay one this
game bought people go yeah we just
wanted starfox and then they make a Star
Fox - this does really well and then
they go okay this sort of thing works we
can apply that to Star Fox I hate to say
it look the success
this game kinda has the fate of like
starfox in its hands cuz like if it does
really well with having starfox in it
that starfox is just gonna be part of
Starling forever and then if it bombs
and then they just go well I guess
starfox sex maybe we should just maybe
not make games I don't know just you
have brought the most depressing part of
III to my apartment brought the most
depressing part of III to my eyeballs I
ran this by you people to hear my
opinion something yell at me in the
content god I can't look at the comment
section no no over looking at the
comment section especially our game
trailer side are you guys excited for
this game I doubt you are this doesn't
look anything special to me or do you
think there should be an actual just I
stuff I wasn't actual starfox game I
would get a switch just for that
well Nintendo you've made everyone super
excited and super sad simultaneously
this is this guy's for yourself Ubisoft
fault
Nintendo certainly had their part to
play was saying oh yeah put starfox in
your game well subscribe to the reject
nation anyway click that notification
bell that cyber channel says channel
make sure to check it out as soon as you
can people